nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code
pacman all right by uh popular demand
i'm going to do a sort of full review of
the andrew cuomo
covid cover-up claims that are
circulating so we can try to
sort of sort out what's truth and what's
lies and what we know about and
what we don't know about and sort of
what's relevant to policy versus what
are sort of like the more
a personal scandals in which andrew
cuomo is now
embroiled so let's get right into it
earlier in the pandemic
new york democratic governor andrew
cuomo was seen
as sort of a model governor in
responding to the pandemic
and despite new york being hit very hard
early
believed to be because of the number of
non-stop flights both to china sort of
like source one for the virus
and italy and surrounding parts of
europe sort of like source two for the
virus in the united states
despite that the idea was that cuomo
handled the virus as well as
was possible given what we knew at the
time and ramped up testing relatively
quickly
as quickly as feasible put in place
guidelines
did shutdowns as necessary and while
much of the united states
had three spikes new york was able to
completely suppress
the what was typically spike two for
much of the country in the middle of the
summer
and they had basically the initial spike
and then the fall spike limiting
themselves to two spikes rather than
three
thanks to andrew cuomo's great work now
until
more recently some very serious
allegations
of the covering up of deaths have
surfaced so let's go through the
allegations
from the emails i've gotten a lot of
people don't actually understand what is
even being alleged
now i want to be up front that much of
much of this is still disputed and
contested
and just about every report has some
detail
that is not at least yet confirmed
but we're going to do the best we can to
parse through the evidence we have
the big scandal and the big allegation
is that at andrew cuomo's either
direction
or uh indifference nursing home
coveted deaths were undercounted by the
state
allegedly to the tune of thousands of
nursing home coveted deaths and indeed
the new york health department has made
public
data that added more than 3 800
nursing home deaths to their tally after
this story broke
and the state now acknowledges that they
upped nursing home deaths by about
40 now it's really important to be clear
here and this is
what a lot of people may be missing this
is not an allegation that new york
under counted covet deaths nationally
even globally we believe
that there have been far more coveted
deaths than the official numbers
because of people who died including at
home and were never tested
but the allegation is not that
the full public number of new york
coveted deaths
is being artificially suppressed any
more than just we're probably under
counting covert deaths at a global level
the current new york coveted death toll
is about 47 000
and that has nothing to do with these
allegations what's at issue
is how many nursing home residents died
and our best understanding of the
undercount is that there were
thousands of nursing home residents who
became so sick
that they went to a hospital died in the
hospital
and they were not counted as nursing
home deaths
now in a literal sense they did die
at the hospital but we all understand
that if you are a nursing home resident
who catches the virus at a nursing home
you should be counted as a nursing home
death from the standpoint of evaluating
how well did andrew cuomo protect
nursing home residents and that's the
crux of this
even if the total number of deaths is
not being lied about if you undercount
nursing home deaths
you are making it seem as though you are
much better protecting nursing homes
than you really are
so this is dishonest and andrew cuomo
has to be held accountable
this has a real impact it's not just
academic it's not just a number
families make decisions about
facilities for loved ones in part based
on whether they believe their loved ones
will or won't be safe
at nursing homes if you falsely believe
that there are way fewer nursing home
cover deaths than there really are
you might make a decision about a loved
one
based on those deceptive statistics so
this is very real
very serious and it has a real world
impact now what are the defenses
the defenses are what we heard from
health commissioner howard zucker from
new york
which is that the state website uh had
always been clear
that deaths it listed uh four nursing
homes
did not include deaths that took place
outside the facility
and that the total number of deaths was
never undercounted that's the defense
from the new york health health
department then there's the second piece
of this
which is the criticism that new york
state
sent nursing home residents who were
hospitalized
back to nursing homes in cases where
they shouldn't have been sent back
this one is more nebulous right now
we're still learning
learning more about it andrew cuomo is
defending this
and saying that everybody that was sent
back was sent back in adherence to
in compliance with federal guidelines
and that they didn't do anything that
was wrong now on the second issue
i'm not really able to put together a
definitive take on it
we just need more information about that
now separately and this is a lot of
stuff happening all at once to andrew
cuomo
separately there are allegations of
andrew cuomo being basically a bad guy
bullying employees and treating
employees terribly
i see this as important but secondary to
the covet scandal
it's a lot of he said she said i can't
possibly analyze it in any serious way
other than to say
all of the allegations should be
investigated and the cards
should fall where they may i don't care
that andrew cuomo is a democrat
whatever whatever is uncovered should be
what it is and uh
it should be dealt with and then lastly
there are also now
new allegations of inappropriate sexual
advances and conduct by andrew cuomo
lindsey boylan who worked for cuomo as
an aide
says that on a private jet cuomo
suggested playing strip poker which made
her feel uncomfortable
uh boylan says that that happened after
she was promoted to be
um cuomo's deputy secretary for economic
development and a special advisor to him
she said she initially turned the job
down because she didn't want to be near
him ultimately accepted it
boylan also is describing an incident
where they were
in his office in new york city on third
avenue and when she got up to leave
and walk out a door that andrew cuomo
allegedly stepped in front of her
kissed her on the lips and that she was
uh shocked but just kept walking out
now this is totally separate and uh
this allegation has to be taken
seriously and fully pursued
so that's the story as i understand it
some of the emails i received
were implying i wasn't going to talk
about this because cuomo is a democrat
first of all we talked about this last
week for a while on the bonus show
secondly i've said a million times i
don't care about these politicians
beyond they're doing things for the
people
i don't care if they're democrats or
republicans i never defended
you know anthony weiner i don't deify
politicians they all have good and bad
and why wouldn't i talk about andrew
cuomo investigate every single thing
if the people of new york want him to
resign he should consider resignation if
there are criminal wrongdoings
then investigate and prosecute we don't
ignore stories
because it's a democrat on this show
that is the full story as
i understand it so really sort of like
four stories the under count of nursing
home deaths
sending patients from hospitals back to
nursing homes
the bullying of employees and the
alleged sexual harassment
of lindsey boylan those are the four
stories as i understand them
they are separate stories we could sort
of group them as
the two covet stories and the two
bullying and harassment stories and
we'll just have to follow all of them
and see where the cards fall
we now have a new poll about americans
view
on the proposed but still not
passed coveted relief bill of joe biden
and democrats
we'll be speaking to democratic
congressman ro khanna a little bit later
today and i'm going to ask him what's
going on and
how quickly does he think this is going
to move forward but there is a
new politico morning consult poll which
shows
that 76 of all americans
strongly support or somewhat support the
covet 19 relief bill
this is the 1.9 trillion dollar bill not
that tiny
600 billion dollar package that some
republicans propose this is the big boy
um only 17 percent of americans
somewhat oppose or strongly oppose the
package the rest
don't even have a have no opinion at
this point and
stunningly among republicans
60 of republican voters
strongly or somewhat support the 1.9
trillion dollar
coveted relief package this is a
really big deal because in the united
it's a big deal for a bunch of different
reasons number one
in the united states over the last eight
to ten years
the level of political division and
polarization makes it really difficult
to ever have
more than 58 or 60 support for almost
anything
after the sandy hook shooting during
barack obama's presidency
there was something like 88 or 90
support for universal background checks
for firearm transactions of all kinds
this means eliminating
every mechanism by which you could
obtain a firearm without a background
check
88 90 support and it still didn't pass
and
if you hadn't been paying attention to
this reality up until then
it was another reminder that our elected
officials
are not actually representing the views
of their constituents because if they
were with 88 to 90
support for that it would have passed we
now are seeing
essentially every republican although i
believe
if it comes down to it some republicans
will vote for the covid 19 relief bill
proposed at 1.9 trillion dollars
because some pragmatic republicans
recognize that their constituents want
it
but at this point you have 76 of the
country saying we want this
pass this it's been proposed
it's been voted on in the house joe
biden wants it democrats want it
uh presumably it would pass the senate
with 50 at minimum 50 votes and kamala
harris is the tiebreaking vote
and yet we aren't seeing any republicans
come out and say this is popular with
the american people and it's my
responsibility to represent them
76 support and even 60
of republicans supporting this and not a
single
republican for now has said let's do
this
i want to vote for this so as i've said
before
let them vote it down democrats
should be spinning this accurately as
this has bipartisan support we're not
talking about
uh uh republican senators who are
against it
we're talking about with the people 76
of the country 60 of republicans support
this
there is rarely anything as bipartisan
when it comes to public support
as this where are republican elected
officials on it
pass it via budget reconciliation or
attempt to
let every single republican who is
committed to voting against it do it
pass it via budget reconciliation you
know you have the votes with 50.
uh joe manchin said he supports it as
far as i last saw that was about a week
ago
kamala harris would be the tie-breaking
vote have joe biden sign it
and if every republican really feels
confident that they can vote against
this without
suffering with their own constituents
let them do it
i don't understand who it is that
republican elected officials are
representing by opposing this certainly
not their constituents
are they i mean you know where we
typically go is are they representing
corporate interests
are they representing donor interests
are they representing
lobbyist interests i i don't exactly
know
but we know that um certain staking out
certain positions for republicans
is very lucrative in terms of
fundraising and maybe that's all that
this is i don't know the answer we'll
talk to ro
khanna about it a little bit later today
but it's time to do it
it's it's just time to get it passed if
you can think of any reason
why democrats at this point should not
go forward with the 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted relief bill
through budget reconciliation requiring
only a simple majority
let me know you can find me on twitter
at deepakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money
helping the environment but it's
actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience than any other shower head
i've used i can get in and out of the
shower way quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only
using about half as much water nebia
also offers a number of shower
accessories like shelves and curtains
which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
percent off
all nebia products
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we are a viewer and listener supported
program and the best way to support the
work we do is simply to grab a
membership on our website it's cheap i
promise
it's quick believe me and it'll feel
really great to be supporting the work
we do plus you get an extra show just
for our paid members every day
go to joinpakman.com that's p-a-k-m-a-n
got a lot of emails saying david i went
there didn't work
but my last name is not p-a-c-m-a-n it's
p-a-k-m-a-n
join pakman.com grab a membership today
we have
a um really rapidly growing discussion
forum
on reddit it is the david pakman show
subreddit now with nearly
30 000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed
for free you can find it at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit a few interesting posts i
spotted this morning one is
um a post called we defeated the flu
amazingly and it's a
screenshot of a dr drew tweet now dr
drew has told some whoppers on covet in
the past
but he is right about this and dr drew
tweeted amazingly
only 165 patients have been hospitalized
with the flu in the united states since
october last season we had 400
000 hospitalizations the staggering
difference may be due to better hygiene
practices
changes in the bacterial gradient field
either way
continue washing your hands well dr drew
is sort of right here i mean
what we know is that coronavirus is more
contagious than the flu it's
are not its reproduction rate is uh when
it's unmitigated
uh is higher than the flu if
you are able to take measures that
prevent the spread
of the flu by sheer mathematical reality
you are also going to prevent the spread
of less contagious things
because we are taking measures many of
us
we have been to stop the spread of
coronavirus the flu which is less
contagious
has been all but completely destroyed i
read
i think it was i'm going from memory
here i believe it's that in the uk
there's only been one pediatric flu
death where normally at this point in
the flu season there would be
way way way more so it's very difficult
to find
anything good out of this pandemic which
has been so destructive
maybe the the advance and and kind of
putting into reality
mrna based vaccines would be something
that would be good and
would be available in the future for
dealing with other
diseases that that's a possibility it's
hard to find anything positive
but certainly the absolute destruction i
would say decimation but i think we've
done even better than
90 reduction in the flu season has been
uh absolutely fantastic another post i
spotted this morning on the subreddit
uh from a user named cop cooper moss who
says
the flag at my local walmart is at half
staff
and i think it was to honor rush
limbaugh writing that quote i'm a truck
driver and delivered to this particular
walmart
walmart store in oregon and notice that
the flag
is at half staff now i can't find any
info online as to any official statement
from the state as to why
other than the whole rush flag debacle i
also know the manager of the store is
really conservative and
looks like he could be russia's fatter
shorter brother
i feel like it shouldn't be up to the
store manager's personal feelings as to
when the flag is lowered or
raised maybe i'm overreacting but for
context about a year ago a driver was
crushed to death when a forklift rolled
over him
and people barely spoke about it the
next day never saw the flag lowered to
respect someone who literally died
working for you
but a homophobic radio personality
across the country deserves that honor
listen i don't know what's going on at
this store um
joe biden ordered flags lowered for five
days
in commemoration and memory of the 500
000 coronavirus deaths
in theory the timing at this walmart
could be over that
although if it's a hardcore right-wing
store manager i don't know
but there's actually a lot of stories of
really
random and relatively obscure places
even
lowering their flags in honor of rush
limbaugh
and um yeah i i think that rush limbaugh
was a terrible influence
on this country and on this planet uh
but you are seeing
a lot of people who want to honor his
memory as if he did something
good which is really destructive
and sad to see join the discussion on
the david pakman show
subreddit at davidpakman.com slash
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
if this story were not
a tragedy of ignorance among our elected
leaders
it would be the stuff of comedy legend
but sadly
it's not because it's so serious what am
i talking about well
democrats now support a 15 an hour
minimum wage nationally
republican senator from south dakota
john thune
opposes a 15 minimum wage and he tweeted
that
15 an hour is just too much
and his evidence is that back when he
was a youngster
he only earned six dollars per hour
tweeting quote i started working by
busing tables
at the star family restaurant for a
dollar an hour
and slowly moved up to cook the big
leagues for a kid
like me to earn six dollars an hour
businesses in small towns
survive on narrow margins mandating a
fifteen dollar minimum wage
would put many of them out of business
now john thune is of course either
forgetting or ignoring
something called inflation for a moment
forget about a productivity adjusted
minimum wage
forget about a cost of living adjusted
minimum wage
let's just deal with inflation john
thune is 60 years old
he said when i was a kid let's say that
it was when he was 18 years old i i
my guess is we don't know what year this
was but we'll say he wasn't 14 he wasn't
16. let's assume he was actually already
18
years old when he was talking about this
when he was working at the star family
restaurant that would put it at 1979
or more than 40 years ago
merely adjusting for inflation six
dollars per hour
in 1979 would be 21.62 cents per hour
today
and he's opposed to a 15
minimum wage based on what he earned
in the late 1970s is this some kind of
bad joke i mean like tell me this is a
bad dream
and he's not really this ignorant and
maybe he's not
maybe he's doing this because he knows
it's his followers
that are actually the ignorant ones now
i will be the first to admit i've
conceded before i've talked about this
before
there are legitimate questions that can
be brought up
about a 15 minimum wage in some places
for example
in a state like alabama which has no
state minimum wage meaning the
prevailing minimum wage there
is the federal one of 7.25 an hour
alabama
has a 7.25 an hour minimum wage cost of
living
is really low it's one of the lowest in
the country there is a legitimate
question to think about if you more than
double the minimum wage in alabama where
cost of living is so much lower than in
many other parts of the country
what does happen to a primarily to a
service-based business where labor is
the primary input now
again i'm not talking about mcdonald's
where labor is not the primary input but
rather it's
rent uh of the of the facility supplies
the food i'm talking about like really a
service-based small business in alabama
where they have to double more than
double whatever every employee is making
we can talk about that i think that's a
perfectly reasonable thing
to discuss but john thune's argument
i made six dollars an hour in 1979
so 15 is too much today even though six
back then
is more than 21 in today's dollars
that's a non-thinking argument
he's making a great argument for a large
increase to the minimum wage
he made six dollars an hour 40 years ago
the federal minimum wage is only 725
right now and it's 40 years later if
there is ever a better argument that the
minimum wage is too low
it's that 40 years ago he made six and
now it's only 7.25
now the more likely scenario
is that john thune does understand this
and that ignoring inflation
makes his argument ridiculous but he's
putting out an argument that his
republican followers
will fall for merely to so doubt which
is how
these propaganda battles are won and
lost get
people to hear that talking point over
and over and over again and repeat it
even if it's obviously ridiculous
another popular one for the anti-minimum
wage people is
listen if more money is good why stop at
15 an hour make it 50
or 100 or a thousand dollars an hour
give everybody a thousand dollars an
hour
and then everybody will be rich and of
course that ignores
that calculating what the minimum wage
should be is not just a calculation of
what would you like to earn oh you want
to make 500 grand a year great yeah
let's figure that out
no you have to have a minimum wage that
in context
is an equilibrium wage adjusted for
inflation
cost of living productivity etc
and there is no mathematical argument
there's no economic argument you could
make
for a hundred dollar an hour minimum
wage i've not heard anyone
advocate for that so we'll have more
about this my question which you can
answer find us on instagram at
davidpakmanshow and you can answer there
do you think john thune is this stupid
or do you think
he knows about inflation and just
assumes his followers are that stupid
that they'll
fall for this follow us on instagram at
david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world famous bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we are welcoming back to the
program congressman ro
khanna representing california's 17th
district
located in the heart of silicon valley
congressman always great to have you on
great to be on
so let's just start with the covid
relief bill um
popular with 76 percent of americans
even 60
of republicans rarely do you see such
agreement among uh 330 million americans
on anything
um 1.9 trillion dollars many people
wondering
what what are we waiting on right now
exactly
well we're going to pass it this week in
the house and then it goes to the senate
so we're waiting as often
on the senate uh and most of the bill is
going to go through the big debate as
you know
is whether the minimum wage will be uh
part of it the increase to 15
is at this point do you think
that understanding how popular the bill
is nationally
that republicans in the senate are
really going to stand in the way
or will some of them take the more
pragmatic approach of realizing that
this is popular even with many of their
constituents
and it makes sense to to be on the right
side so to speak
you would think that but that's not the
indication i mean when you have mitt
romney coming out saying that
this is too big a bill and too much
spending i mean if he's not going to be
for it doesn't give me much hope that
you're going to get many uh republicans
for it so i expect unfortunately that
this will be a straight party-line vote
how soon would the stimulus deposits
and or checks start getting to people if
it was passed
sometime next week it would be a few
weeks typically i mean i know
in the previous administration it
dragged on for
months and we still have some people who
are asking about
the 600 check from last time so i
hope we've learned from that typically
it takes about two to three weeks for
people to see the check after the
president signs it
in your mind would this be the last
coveted stimulus
i hope not i have called with tim ryan
since the
covert crisis began for monthly checks
because people's rent comes due every
month there
a lot of folks who aren't getting
unemployment benefits i think we have to
continue until
uh the crisis is over until our
economy is fully open again and i'm
going to continue to push for that
what metrics would you look at to
determine
when that is i guess i would look at the
unemployment rate
but not just the unemployment rate but
people who have opted out of the
workforce i would look at the infection
rate and the prevalence and seeing
uh how much we've been able to open up
our
economy again the 15 minimum wage which
is part of the version that is currently
um
uh in in your chamber in the house of
representatives if that doesn't
ultimately get included in the bill is
that the next thing you'd like to see
congress take up or is there something
else
i would because it's the one thing that
represents structural change so the bill
is very important it gets money to stay
in local governments it gives money for
vaccines it gets money
uh of cash for every individual but it's
not structurally changing the economy
the minimum wage does it would
fundamentally increase wages for people
the challenges and bernie sanders made
this point yesterday that
you can't do the minimum wage without uh
reconciliation they're just not 60 votes
so
you either have to get rid of the
filibuster or you have to do
reconciliation
which is why it's so important to get
this in the current bill
um when we talk about uh the immigration
situation
we covered on the program earlier this
week how
joe biden did very quickly do this
executive order
to stop the removals of um
undocumented immigrants back to a number
of different countries
but a judge very quickly kibboshed that
and since correct me if i'm wrong joe
biden has not attempted
with a different legal justification to
do another executive order and i've read
a number of interesting legal
assessments that say if joe biden was
really determined to do this
there are a number of other ways that he
could word and structure executive
orders
the it was a it was very um
narrowly stopped by this texas judge and
joe biden hasn't done that
i've said that i think that if indeed
this is the priority joe biden said it
would be and that i believe it should be
he should be going right back at this
with another executive order and another
what do you think i agree with you i
mean i think that
uh we shouldn't let one judge stop the
process of having a more humane
uh immigration policy and the biggest
concern to me are
the kids and i'm sure you read also on
the on the detention
uh and sending them there now there are
alternatives you can have community
detention you can a community
placement uh and uh it's a question of
having the resources and the plan
so i think that this has to be looked at
i've looked
i'm on camilla j paul's road map for
immigration she's going to be putting
out a plan on
how we keep our borders safe but are not
treating most of the migrants coming
over particularly kids as criminals
so if job if joe biden doesn't do it if
he just leaves it as
i did an executive order and a judge
stopped it and i guess now we have to
wait
would you consider that a failure
i don't think that's true to uh what he
ran on i mean we
every democratic candidate running said
that we were going to
look at the inhumane uh trump policy and
and return to a policy
of not criminalizing most people
crossing the border that
it is a civil infraction it you can be
uh sent back but uh there has to be a
move
that we aren't treating uh mothers and
kids as criminals and that we're placing
them in
uh in community placements instead of
these detention centers
in terms of the makeup of the house of
representatives
right now when we look at national
polling
among republican voters for the most
part the support of the former president
trump is is still significant um
something like 80 percent of republicans
want him to remain involved
64 percent said if he split off and
started his own party
that they would follow him now i expect
that in practice
those numbers would be lower i i think
the idea of splitting off is more
appealing than
right actually doing it but needless to
say for the time being there's continued
support among the republican party for
the former president
what is your assessment right now of the
impact within
your legislative body of the presence of
folks like
marjorie taylor greene and lauren
beaubert and madison cawthorne who
arguably are only even there
by riding on the coattails of trumpism
in the last six months of 2020.
well they've been marginalized uh from
the body but the challenge is that there
were almost 140
republicans who voted for the uh the
opposing the certification of the
election yeah and
that's a lot of that's not just some of
these extreme cases
and so the decision the republican party
has to make and it's a very difficult
decision
is how do they move beyond trump uh
without abdicating
their base and i i don't think any
republican actually has
uh figured that out i mean you have
nikki haley taking a different side of
the
equation every day because they're
trying that balancing act
but uh and they've seen the consequences
of a liz cheney or someone who
tries a clean break and uh until they
are able to get
a coherent vision of a post-trump future
they're going to struggle is it naive to
think that this
fracturing particularly if this divide
becomes more noticeable
if donald trump does start his own party
or if he announces
at cpac on sunday that he's running as a
republican in 2024
any of these things that might fracture
these two sides is it naive for me to
think that it's an opportunity for the
left to get things done while they are
fighting amongst themselves
well i i think for the sake of the
country it would be better to have a
a coherent uh party that rejects uh
racism and that moves beyond trump but
what i would say is we have all the
tools we need but
we don't even have to focus right now on
the republicans what we have to do is
focus on how
uh controlling the house controlling the
senate the presidency we get our
things through and we ought to be doing
aggressively through reconciliation
the 15 wage the covered relief
infrastructure
uh and expanding health care so uh i
think we have an opportunity to
deliver on our agenda on health care
what do you see as as the next step
not in in a perfect world where we might
be talking about medicare for all or
something else but
based on what joe biden ran on is it is
it
a simple let's establish a public option
what is it that you see as the immediate
next step on health care
well we should expand medicare and he
ran on expanding it to 60. that seems to
me an easy
yeah left we should look at how we at
least get
a public uh option uh that
is uh affordable uh as a step towards
a single player i mean i believe
fundamentally medicare for all
is the right solution right but if
they're what i would say is
let's look at any step in the lens of is
it getting us closer to that
uh ultimate goal and if and we should
support those parts that are
helping us move in that direction in
your mind does this have to be done
before 2022 because we simply don't know
who will control what after that point
i do i mean i think it has to be done
not for the
sake of politics with people say oh if
you don't do this you'll lose the house
i just think
it's so rare in american politics if you
have the presidency the senate and the
house
and if we don't do this uh who knows
when all those stars align again
uh we're working very very hard to make
sure we keep the house i know senator
schumer's working hard to keep the
senate
and i think we have a very good chance
but politics is unpredictable and while
we have this opportunity let's deliver
on some structural change to improve
people's lives
in terms of the day-to-day in the house
you know we've had these stories about
metal detectors and we've learned about
um
congressman kawthorne saying that with
with his wheelchair he's able to
actually have multiple firearms with him
uh and and it's not obvious to others
that that's what's going on
are are you feeling uh worried
day-to-day about
firearms at the capitol i personally am
not but i feel i worry for colleagues i
worry for some of the women of color
who've been
uh subject to many death threats i've i
i worry for people who have
uh been outspoken and targets on
uh on right-wing media uh and then i'm
sad for a country that every time i go
to the capitol
it's basically a fortress you have
barbed wire you have
uh the national guard i mean it's a sad
thing that
we've created that distance between
government and people
uh because of the threats that uh are
there on the building
so you're not necessarily changing your
protocol
but much has changed at the capitol yeah
i mean everyone
is more vigilant that's just uh common
sense and
me and our team are more vigilant we
probably lock the doors more we're more
careful
we're making sure that we're not taking
unnecessary risks but
personally i don't feel uh threatened in
the way that some of my colleagues
unfortunately have been threatened yeah
uh you mentioned
infrastructure and this is such a big
topic now particularly in light of what
happened in texas
last week and of course we've gone into
detail about the way the texas grid
works the reality of
it's very plausible to winterize wind
turbines wind turbines are not the cause
of this issue
but can you talk a little bit about what
would
a green infrastructure deal look like
what would be the most important things
to include
in terms of the types of subsidies maybe
that would be put in place
the types of jobs that we should be
looking to create how we should be
managing the reality that
for the most part we still do get most
of our energy from fossil fuels at this
point in time
well david i chair the subcommittee on
the environment and we're going to be
holding a hearing on what happened in
texas and you're absolutely right but
one of the questions we're going to ask
with ercot is it's actually cheaper to
weatherize
wind turbines than it is to weatherize
natural gas uh pipelines so
shouldn't this incident have us move
towards
uh renewable energy that's either easier
to weatherize that's easier to build
infrastructure around
we need to be built making that kind of
investment in renewable energy
generation in battery storage in
electric vehicle
and all of these things are going to
create jobs and we ought to have the
federal government help finance it or
take equity in it
because these are large capital projects
in
building the modern infrastructure for
the new energy economy
that is something that's jobs good jobs
and it's also something that's going to
help us tackle climate change
what will it ultimately take though to
to really signal a sea change
in terms of i mean your your state of
california has taken
a pretty definitive position on a new
new vehicle sales will have to be
electric after correct me if i'm wrong
is it 2035
yes some european countries germany for
example has taken
a similar approach but at the national
level rather than at the state level do
you think
ultimately the federal government is
going to have to
make some of those decisions in order to
really move forward
i do i think we ought to set those
centers i think those standards will be
good for american business it's good for
us to lead in electric vehicles rather
than allowing china to lead
and we could create the incentive to
build those plants in places that have
lost
a manufacturing for example lordstown
lordstown ohio lost
an auto plant because uh we have a
demand for suvs over
uh over sedans well why don't we
incentivize that lordstown
lordstown ohio could become an electric
vehicle uh plant manufacturer or a
battery manufacturer one of the things
that's interesting is a lot of the
component parts
of electric vehicles could be made in
the united states
so we have to have a real view of how we
reindustrialize america
and uh if we do that it can be uh
towards climate change tackling it but
also
towards job creation yeah there's a bit
of a myopic view
on on electric cars i mean certainly
right now tesla
is the lion's share of the market and
those are american vehicles
it's unbelievable what what's going on
but when you look at rivian you look at
pole star
you you look at what clearly is a
growing presence of
chinese electric vehicles there's a
particular window of opportunity right
now that it sounds like you're saying
should should be seized before this goes
elsewhere
exactly and china currently leads in the
electric vehicle market i mean they
don't lead in the u.s market but they
lead in the
china market and the worldwide market
and a lot of the electric vehicle
manufacturers does by tesla are there so
we don't want china to eventually be
exporting to europe and to
be exporting to uh the rest of the world
we want uh our
countries to do companies to do that and
that's why it has to be collaborative
with the
government and the private sector to
innovate last thing i want to
ask about two structural issues that we
talk about so much in terms of how
future elections will will work
those are campaign finance how our
elections are financed and paid for
and also how how we count votes right
the idea of
first past the post within an electoral
college system
do you see the possibility of any
reform or changes on either of those two
issues in the next two years is there
even an appetite for it right now within
the biden administration and the
democratic party
well hr1 is all about this and it's a
big idea is to give
individuals matching funds to be able to
contribute
yeah to eliminate big big money uh to
help have redistributed reform i think
it'll pass the house again the question
becomes what happens in the senate yeah
and then the question becomes
what parts will a roberts court hold uh
constitutional my view is the big
the simplest thing is to make every
voter a donor give every person a 50
credit to be able to use uh on campaigns
to democratize
uh finance and uh lessen the value of
big money
yeah well i mean one interesting piece i
read said that that's a great
half measure but ideally you would
eliminate all of that and simply have
straight public financing of elections
do you see
that democratization of funds as
an intermediate step or is the end goal
i see it as an intermediate step i mean
i would love public financing of
elections but that just would be struck
down as unconstitutional under
uh the way this court has held blackley
beast vallejo and understanding the
money of speech so the voucher proposal
that larry lessig and some others have
come up with is to say that it's
constitutional even under a roberts
court
and if we can't get rid of the
billionaire spending money
at least we can dwarf them with citizen
resources and so that's the idea but i
obviously it is a half measure
absolutely last thing we just learned
about joe biden's plan
to essentially pack the postal service
board of governors
adding three individuals so that then
louis de joy could be removed
does that sound to you like it will
happen as smoothly and as quickly as
summer are hoping
it should i hope so i applaud the
president for doing that i mean
lewiston joy was just a disaster not
just because of his trying to
play games with the election but his
view that you would basically privatize
the post service and that that was never
the intention when
private companies can explain to me how
they're going to guarantee
mail going across country for 50 cents
and the speed it does
that we could talk but the reality is
they can't and there's a reason that we
have
a postal service that is a public entity
and we shouldn't be privatizing the few
public entities that are working in this
country
absolutely let's let's hope it does
happen that quickly and smoothly
uh congressman ro khanna of course from
california 17th district
always great uh catching up with you
thank you david thanks for having me as
always
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so i am um optimistically hoping
that there are going to be travel
possibilities
coming up over the next uh six to nine
months i do
in theory have a wedding in europe i'm
supposed to go to in september
so i sent in my passport for renewal on
january 5th
this year and i sent it by regular
postal mail
and it wasn't even received by the
passport processing center for nearly
three weeks until the last week of
january
and the postal service has never been
more kneecapped than it is right now and
a big part of the reason
is donald trump's choice for postmaster
general lewis de joy
who has been wreaking havoc at the post
office for the better part of
a year longer at this point in time
louis de joy
insisted at a hearing yesterday that
we'd better get damn used to him
because he plans to stay in his position
a long time take a look
you're a political appointee a holdover
um
no one knows how much longer you're born
that's that's incorrect i'm not a
political appointee i was selected by a
bipartisan board of governors
and i would really appreciate if you
would get that straight
well how much longer are you planning to
stay
in a long time get used to me
well joe biden has a clear plan to
removing louis de joy
which would be really great for the
country and anyone who either
sends or receives mail which is most
people
for everyone wondering why louis de joy
is still on the job and why joe biden
hasn't simply removed him and replaced
him with someone else
it's because the postal service board of
governors
chooses the postmaster general it's not
as simple as joe biden can just
replace louis de joy so what joe biden
and congress
are going to need to do is to fix the
postal board of governors before they
can have them removed the only other way
i can think of
uh removing the postmaster general would
be for joe biden to make it a cabinet
level position
so he can just pick a new postmaster
general that seems like it would be
relatively difficult to do
so what joe biden is planning to do is
he is going to nominate
three additional members to the u.s
postal service board of governors
if joe biden's nominees are confirmed by
the senate
this would then give democrats and
democratic appointees
the majority of that postal service
board of governors it's almost like he
is
packing the court except it's packing
the postal service board of governors
having that majority
the postal service could then vote to
remove louis de joy
from the position of postmaster general
the three nominees
uh for joe biden are reportedly going to
be ron strowman who's a former deputy
postmaster general
amber mcreynolds the ceo of vote at home
which promotes voting by mail
and anton hajjar who's the former
general counsel
for the american postal workers union so
the plan is very clear
nominate these three folks they get
approved by the majority
democratic senate you get a majority on
the postal board of governors and then
you get rid of louis de joy now whether
it will happen
that smoothly remains to be seen but
this is an emergency as a reminder the
postal service
has been a target of the american right
wing for a long time
remember that the way this fits in is
that the right wants the government
doing nothing
and as an independent agency under the
executive branch of the government the
right
really wants to get rid of the postal
service one thing they've done
is required that the postal service
pre-fund
pensions of workers decades in advance
which on paper
makes the financial situation of the
postal service look much worse than it
actually is
no for-profit industry has to pre-fund
pensions that far in advance it was a
calculated measure
by the right to argue that the postal
service is financially insolvent
another way to hurt the post office is
to make it work
so poorly that people stop using it
which then makes it
even less viable and lewis the joy has
done many things to make the postal
service work less efficiently
including eliminating overtime pay for
mail carriers so that undelivered mail
at the end of the normal work day
instead of getting delivered
simply goes back to the post office and
gets delayed sometimes for one day
sometimes for many many days and as
we've seen
under louis de joy on time mail delivery
has declined from 96 percent to 80
percent
some parts of the country like detroit
even lower 74 percent on time
mail delivery and this is sadly
a key part of the republican playbook
rail against a government department or
a government entity or a government
uh an organization overseen by the
government
then put they get themselves put in
charge of running it
they make it run even worse and then
they say look we told you guys this is
terrible well yeah you're making it
terrible
and then somehow they'll blame democrats
and then when democrats come in
and put together a plan to fix what
republicans ruined
republicans say who can afford that
that's really expensive this thing is
functioning so terribly
we would need so much money to fix it we
can't afford that well why is it running
so terribly
it's running so terribly because you
destroyed it so it's a very
common republican playbook and uh
it is one that unfortunately has worked
well
in many areas so we see the path
three new postal board of governors
members
postal service board of governor members
get them confirmed
by the democratically controlled senate
vote to remove louis de joy
put someone in that position who
actually wants to improve the
functioning of the postal service
rather than worsen it which is exactly
what louis de joy wanted to do
and it's exactly what he has done we got
him ladies and gentlemen
donald trump's tax records have finally
been put in the hands of the new york
district attorney you might remember
that late last week the supreme court
made a decision
donald trump can't keep shielding his
tax returns
from the new york district attorney and
the grand jury that has been convened
donald trump has fought for years and it
has taken years to make this a reality
trump has fought for years to keep his
tax returns
secret why has he done it we don't know
presumably donald trump has made the
calculation maybe accurately
that what is in the tax returns getting
out is far
worse for him than the criticisms
for keeping the tax returns secret in
any case
prosecutors now have the tax returns as
of monday
they got them just hours after the
supreme court
said no to the trump final appeal
for keeping those records private this
includes millions of pages of documents
according to sources which include
trump's tax returns going from january
of 2011
to august of 2019 financial statements
engagement agreements documents relating
to the preparation of his tax returns
work papers communications related to
the tax returns and this
is a treasure trove of information now
as a reminder
none of this legally is to be released
to the public
the release of these tax returns and
other financial records
are two new york prosecutors
for the purposes of investigation and
use
with the grand jury that has been
convened now
is it possible that these documents will
be leaked of course
of course i don't i'm not counting
significantly on that particularly when
it's widely known where they would have
come from this is the only
entity now that has had these documents
uh
turned over to them i think that the
risk would be high
of deliberately leaking them uh could
they leak in some other way
yeah maybe maybe at this point
it's less about at this point i don't
think even if they were to leak no
matter what's in them
i don't think it would have a
significant impact but
there is still sort of just a curiosity
that i have like what is in them that is
so bad that donald trump didn't want
them released and we've speculated
before
one of the revelations of trump's tax
returns
could be one that would simply affect
trump from the standpoint of vanity that
the tax returns may reveal that donald
trump is not
nearly as wealthy as he has claimed to
be and that would be a reason for trump
to want to keep them hidden
more for vanity than for any kind of
legal repercussions however
it is conceivable that these tax returns
would reveal even more deception from
donald trump about the value of assets
when it's advantageous to inflate the
value versus when it's advantageous to
downplay the value
and it could get donald trump into
financial trouble
it could expose certain liabilities or
other connections that donald trump has
although
much of that would really be in a
financial disclosure more than in tax
returns so there's still a question mark
as to what exactly
would be there but we simply won't know
if and until we actually get these
documents released so they are now in
the hands
of new york prosecutors once the supreme
court ruled it happened very very
quickly
and we will see ultimately if we learn
more about their contents i'm not
holding my breath
but i would be fascinated yesterday i
did a segment on the show
where i ran through an email exchange i
had
with an anti-vaccine conspiracy theorist
and um she disappeared after i asked for
the documents she claimed to have and i
got a bunch of different emails and
voicemails about this and i'm going to
play a voicemail for you that raises an
issue that's actually a much bigger
issue
than just with anti-vaxx folks and it's
a delicate issue
it relates to mental illness let's take
a listen to this
and then i want to i want to treat it
with with the seriousness that it
uh that that it should be treated with
take a listen
hi david this is collins big fan has
been a member of your show since the
start of coven listened
every single day so your streams are
always released in times of crisis like
january 6
which is much appreciated but my
question recently you have an email
correspondence with an individual named
amy who is deep into a number of
conspiracies particularly around
covenant vaccines
so my sister suffers from a number of
mental disabilities and also speaks with
these issues in a
similar manner so what do you feel if
anything
we can do as a society to reach out to
loved ones friends acquaintances
strangers even who believe in this false
reality
and also we ever take a hard look at the
mental illness conspiracy connection and
then the impact it has on our political
course
thank you this is a really good
voicemail
and a serious topic and you know this
has come up before on the show where
we will look at some of these wildly
religious zealots and sometimes they'll
call into the show
and sometimes i i do get uncomfortable
and will get away
from reviewing some of their content
because it comes clear that
they do seem to be suffering from some
kind of of severe mental illness and
without diagnosing anyone
with some of these extreme religious
zealots who call me about
biden is the the riding in on a white
horse and this prophecy and that problem
at a certain point
it it sort of becomes indistinguishable
from someone having a psychotic episode
someone suffering from paranoid
delusions etc
we've talked with experts on conspiracy
theories and conspiracism on the program
before
and they've said that yes mental illness
emotional trauma unmedicated undiagnosed
mental illness
there is a significant interplay between
that and people who go
down the so-called rabbit hole really
deeply with a lot of this stuff
and unfortunately from from our
standpoint when we're observing
anti-vax ideas that are out there it can
be difficult to
to determine what is what there's no
question
that with a lot of extreme thinking
so thinking not just oh vaccines can
have side effects but they're very safe
and if you have side effects here right
like going to this extreme of
the vaccines are killing people you're
part of the cover-up and that's part of
the cover-up and
all this different stuff um their
emotional trauma and things going on in
people's lives can play a big role in
people
falling for that there's many examples i
i know of people
um who uh let's see how i can even say
this
these are folks folks i grew up with
actually who
after a traumatic event of different
kinds in in one case
it was a sexual assault in another case
it was
another type of family trauma they
became
extreme when it comes to diet
to the point where they were hopping
between
extreme diets one where you only ate
fruit like a lunch could be like a dozen
bananas or something like that
um to another diet of only
okay different things that doesn't
matter what the specifics are
and the sort of connection to the trauma
is very very clear
and much the same way that sometimes
after
trauma some people simply become
depressed or some people
become anxious or some people develop
agoraphobia they don't want to leave
their house
there's no question that if opportunity
strikes and circumstances are right
that same type of trauma or simply
long-term undiagnosed
mental illness can make it so that oh
it's it's vaccines that that's the topic
right now
well i'm going to jump into the vaccine
conspiracy theories or whatever the case
may be
so unfortunately this relates to to far
bigger issues
number one it relates to lack of access
to mental health resources and also
stigma around mental health
services that that really shouldn't be
there and this can apply to
any kind of conspiracism conspiratorial
thinking paranoid delusions psychotic
episodes all of this type of stuff
from the standpoint of policy you know
it's very difficult
to have to evaluate uh
the the sort of um emotional state of
individuals when we
are debunking this uh flawed thinking so
it's a really really tough thing
i i think it's important to handle it
delicately and we don't want to further
stigmatize mental illness but there is
no question that
you know when i get 20 anti-vaxxed
emails
some portion of those people are are
less
people that are truly researching and
and convinced about this particular
thing this is just the current
outward manifestation of what could be
all sorts of
uh emotional mental health and and
psychiatric issues and it is
a very complicated situation so i don't
know what else to say about it other
than
i i'm aware of this and i don't exactly
know
how to best deal with it we have a great
bonus show for you today
um we will reveal just how close
texas was during the power outage to a
power outage that could have actually
extended
into the months rather than the days
it's it's shocking what we're learning
about what's going on there
the south dakota attorney general is now
facing impeachment and calls to resign
over new evidence in a fatal uh our car
crash which we will discuss
and we didn't have time to talk about
this i do want to talk about this entire
kim jong-un ride home on air force one
thing that's been floating around
so we will have all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show
i hope you'll sign up and grab a
membership at joinpakman.com it's cheap
it's easy you'll be supporting the show
and you'll get instant access to today's
bonus show i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman